Researcher Dan selected one airline ticket
to Hawaii, along with seven blank tickets,
for experimentation.
Before beginning the test, he made this note:
“This is not duplication for personal gain,
it's merely a work field trip for the broke”
He placed all of the tickets inside, turned
the machine to the setting "Very Fine," and
waited.
This was the output produced:
Several small economy airline tickets for
Researcher Darby.
When Researcher Dan attempted retrieval they
folded into paper airplane's reminiscent to
C-130's and attempted to escape containment.
Four were captured by staff, two were shot
by onsite weapons, namely the H20-9000, and
one escaped retrieval by entering the air
vents and has presumably escaped.